so today I want to try and bend your
brains a little bit today and I'm hoping
it will cause a little bit of debates on
on the comments because I know YouTube's
the home of rational in uniform to
debate so I'll look forward to that the
question is what is this equal to it's
quite a simple sum it starts with 1 then
I'm going to subtract 1 then I'm going
to add 1 again then subtract 1 then add
1 then subtract 1 then add 1 and
subtract 1 and I'm going to do this
forever you get the idea of that I hope
so what is that equal to so one of the
answers that it might be is if I put the
brackets like this here and here and
here here you can see each bracket is 1
minus 1 plus 1 minus 1 plus 1 minus 1
each bracket is 0 so you're getting 0
plus 0 plus 0 plus 0 forever so that's
going to be equal to 0 isn't it that's
one of the answers it could be the
problem is there is another answer if I
do it again we could put the brackets
here like this and then let's say this
is Plus again there Plus this bracket so
I've started with 1 plus minus 1 plus 1
that's a 0 plus minus 1 plus 1 that's a
zero executive cetera all the brackets
are 0 so all the brackets add up to 0
but I've got a 1 at the start so now
this is equal to 1 I've got two answers
I've got 0 if I put the brackets here
I've got 1 if I put the brackets in a
different place there is a third answer
as well and this is the very weird one
let's say it has a number so just call
it s we're going to try and find out
what S is equal to that's what we want
to know let's do 1 minus s so it's 1
minus this infinite sum let's do that so
let's write it out plus 1 minus 1 plus 1
minus 1 plus 2 right if we take the
bracket away this minus number will mean
that all the side
we'll get flipped so you'll get 1 minus
1 plus 1 minus 1 plus 1 minus 1 that's
what happens when I take away the
bracket buts what I end up with is the
thing I started with that's just the
alternating plus and minus 1 so I've got
s again so I've got 1 minus s is equal
to s that's ok you can thus find you can
solve that in other words if I take the
S to the other side I've got 2 s equals
1 which then you can see that s is equal
to 1/2
that's a weird answer I've got half the
the sum of adding plus and minus 1
forever
gives you a half or he might be one it
might be 0 but it might be 1/2 so the
guy who came up with this idea was an
Italian mathematician called Ronde this
in 1703 he was a monk he was a
mathematician he was one of those types
and he published this and he said this
is weird it's 0 its 1 its 1/2 what's
what's that all about and the
mathematical community had to look at it
and he said well it can't be 1/2 can it
I mean you've got ones and zeros that's
madness it can't be oh hang on oh that's
actually quite convincing it might be
1/2 so there was a debate about this if
for a long time like 150 years quite a
debate until the 19th century when all
this all this stuff with infinite sums
really got sorted out a lot of people
think that the best answer is 1/2 I want
to try and show you why they think the
best answer is 1/2 and then when I've
done that I'm gonna show you one more
thing to completely bend your brain if
we pick a nice infinite sum because
there are nice infinite sums and there
are bad infinite sums one of the nice
ones is this 1 plus 1/2 plus 1/4 plus
1/8 plus 1/16 the way you can work out
the answer for that actually going to
show you the proper way to do it the
proper way to do it is look at the
partial sums we're going to add this sum
term by term
let's just make a sequence of them I
start with one I'll write that down
what do I get if I had the first two
terms it's 1 plus 1/2 it's actually 3
halves if you prefer that's 1.5 let's
add the first three numbers together so
1 plus 1/2 plus 1/4 let's do that seven
quarters
it's 1.75 if I add the first 4 together
15 over 8 which is one point eight seven
five and if you did then you know the
next lot you get 63 over 32 1.96 875 you
might be able to see they're getting
closer and closer to the value 2 in
general if I picked one in general it
would be 2 minus 1 over N and if you can
see yes the n gets bigger this gets tiny
and disappears and you just left with 2
and mathematicians are justified in
saying that the whole infinite sum is
equal to 2 if we try Ricordi series it
doesn't work look at the partial sums
the first one is 1 then you have the
first two together you're gonna get to 0
you have the first 3 together you get 1
again you had the first 4 together you
get back to 0 and it keeps alternating
between ones and zeroes and it's not
getting closer to a value so this
doesn't work we've gone this series so
I'm going to show you a second method to
work out sums I'm going to take the
partial sums and I'm going to look at
the averages I'm just going to average
as I go along almost the same I'll do it
with this one first to show you the idea
I'm going to add the let's take the
first one that's one we're add the first
two partial sums together so 1 plus 1.5
but our average it I'm going to divide
by 2 so it's going to be 1 plus 3 halves
and then average it like that which is
actually equal to 5 quarters if I took
the first 3 and averaged them I would
have 1 plus 3 halves for seven quarters
divided by 3
and that gives me 17 over 12 and well
hopefully you get the idea of that again
the numbers are tending closer and
closer to two it's just another method
to get the same answer
it gives me two again in fact in general
what you gets to minus some junk are the
junk isn't important look
it's junk but this this junk is getting
smaller and smaller and smaller so
you're getting two again it's just
another way to find the same answer but
this method can be used with Gandhi's
series let's try it
we're averaging the partial sums so
those the partial sums we start with 1
then if you average the first two you
get 1 plus 0 divided by 2 which is 1/2
take the first three and then divide by
3 gives me 2/3
I take the first 4 1 plus 0 plus 1 plus
0 divided by 4 that's another half again
forget that right take first 5 so you
might be able to see what's going on
here divided by 5 so that's 3/5 what
happens is in general heat going in
general you'll get 1/2 followed by
something like R 1/2 plus 1 over 2n
there we go again so you get some junk
here that's going smaller and smaller
and smaller this is all tending towards
1/2 so together you're zoning in on to
the number 1/2 so this is more technical
than the other version I did but it's a
second way to get sums
yeah average the partial sums but it
works for Gandhi's series it gives me a
half so what's what's going on what's
the difference this second method it
gives you some when there are some
defined a limit is when you're getting
closer and closer to the value now
Gandhi's series does not have a limit
because you're not getting closer and
closer to the value but you have this
second way of finding a sum it's almost
like a limit but it's not really a limit
it's a fake limit it's a pseudo limit it
has all the properties of limits it does
all the same things it's so close
- being a limit that it turns up in
calculations where you expect limits to
turn up but the difference is you're not
getting closer and closer and closer to
really bend your brain try and imagine
this we're going to try and imagine
doing this in the real world imagine a
light we're going to turn the light on
and off so you turn the light on you
turn the light off now every time if I'd
go along grandi series every time I see
a one I turn the light on
every time I see a minus one I turned
the light off so you can aren't you turn
it off you turn it on you turn it off
the partial sums actually tell you if
the light is on or off if you have a one
that means you just turned it on you
have a zero that means you've just
turned it off you're going to start an
experiment after one minute you turn the
light on after half a minute you then
turn the light off again after a quarter
of a minute you turn the light on after
an eighth of a minute you turn the light
off and you're turning it on and off but
you're doing it quicker and quicker and
quicker so you're doing that infinitely
many times but if we add up the time
together one minute
plus half a minute plus quarter of a
minute plus 1/8 of a minute forever
adds up to two minutes in fact that's
what series I did there if you remember
the video we did about Zeno's paradox
that's not just getting closer to two
minutes you can actually complete it and
finish the whole process in two minutes
so in two minutes time you'll have
turned on on and off the light
infinitely many times and completed it
after two minutes it's the light on or
off if the grandees series is zero that
means the light is off if grandees
series is 1 that means the light is on
if grandis series is 1/2 what what does
that mean is that is it half on half off
is it on and off at the same time what
do you think of course so he's given a
head start he's got 100 meter head start
and then they start the race
now our kilise Sprint's 100 meters and
he catches up to where the toy toys what
but in that time the Protoss has moved
on